welcome back so in the last video we saw
that if we want full state estimation if
we want the full state to be observable
with some measurement Y then the only
state the only single measurement we can
use is the carts position X of T okay
because all of the other ones were
unobservable I only checked one of them
but you could check the observability of
all the other measurements and they're
all unobservable but this actually
raises a really interesting question
which is what if I actually don't care
about the carts exact position but all I
care about is that I can stabilize the
inverted pendulum so I can make X dot
equals zero theta equals PI and theta
dot equals zero okay so I want to
stabilize the inverted pendulum but I
don't care what x position the cart is
in okay so this is the kind of question
that we have in control systems
sometimes which is the original stage of
the system that I wrote down maybe I
only care about three of these variables
okay so maybe I care a lot more about
these three variables and I want to know
is there a subsystem in terms of just
these three variables that is observable
with a different measurement okay so
that's what I'm going to talk about here
so the basic framing is we found that
it's actually pretty hard to estimate
the full state if I include the carts
position X of T essentially because it
doesn't enter the dynamics anywhere so I
have to directly measure it but if I
don't care about the translational
position of this card I just care that
it's stabilized maybe I can get away
with just estimating X dot theta and
theta dot the bottom three states okay
so that's what we're going to look at
here so we have another script
essentially which measurements are best
if we omit X so I'm going to take my
original four by four a matrix my
original four by one B matrix and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to build a
sub system of just the lower three by
three a matrix and the lower three by
one B matrix so you'll see here I'm
essentially redefining a two
be the lower 3x3 block let me write this
up I have I have this a matrix and what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
redefine a to be this bottom 3x3 block
and I had this B matrix and I'm going to
redefine B to be this bottom 3 by 1
matrix okay that's what I'm doing here
in line 33 and 34 and now we're going to
see given this new C vector and so here
our C is going to be something like how
do we want to do this so now we're
completely neglecting X so if I measure
1 0 0 here this is measure X dot right X
dot and let's see if the system is
observable if we measure this X dot okay
so we're going to run this code so I've
loaded all of these variables now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to look at
the observability matrix of a comma C
this new 3x3 system and now notice that
the system is full rank it spans all of
its column space and so if I measure X
dot that is enough to infer X dot theta
and theta dot so that subsystem if I
don't care about X is observable which
is really cool let's try this again and
let's see what if I measure your theta
so now this is measure theta now I'm
going to look at OVS be a comma C okay
it's a little bit less obvious but let's
take the determinant of this and see if
it is equal to 0 or not okay so the
determinant of this is nonzero which
means that this system is also
observable so if I measure theta the
position of the of the pendulum I can
also infer X dot theta and theta dot
okay so this system is also observable
and let's just double check everything
so now let's try measuring theta dot
okay run that and now I'm going to look
at OBS V a comma C so again my
observability matrix and let's take the
determinant again again since the
determinant is nonzero that means that
even if I measure say to dot the rate of
change of theta that's still enough
information if I know a and B if I know
a and C I can back out X dot theta and
theta dot okay so basically any
measurement of any of these is enough to
fully estimate the state of the full x
dot theta theta dot vector as long as I
don't care about X of T the cart
position so that's really cool
the remember observability just like
controllability is a binary indicator of
yes the system is observable or no the
system's not observable so now what we
can do is we can look at the
observability granion okay and that's
going to be really interesting so we're
going to see which of these measurements
gives me a better a bigger volume of the
observability granion and that'll tell
me which one's a better measurement okay
so now i'm going to uncomment a little
bit of code here so now what I'm going
to do is I'm actually going to build
this system plus D U and here D is equal
to zero but MATLAB wants there to be a
possibility of a feed-through term okay
so I have my a matrix my B matrix I'm
just selecting the subsystem the 3x3
subsystem I'm going to in this case
measure theta dots here in line 37 I'm
building my state space system and then
what's really cool is I can build the
grammy and could be observability grammy
in just using this grand command gram
sis comma oh okay this is V
observability Graham Ian and if I
compute the determinant of that
observability Graham Ian that
essentially gives me the volume of this
observable ellipsoid okay and remember
the different directions in this
observable ellipsoid kind of give me an
indication of how easy it is to observe
these variables given my measurement Y
in another way
thinking it's almost like the the bigger
the observability ellipsoid the higher
signal-to-noise ratio I'm able to pull
out and so I want this determinant which
measures that ellipsoid volume I want
this determinant to be as big as
possible okay so I'm going to go down
here and I'm going to run this code this
is first ADA dot okay so let's run this
code Graham command cannot be used for
models with unstable dynamics ah I did
this for the pendulum up let's try this
for the gantry crane problem let's make
this the pendulum down did everyone
catch that error it said the granion
can't be computed for systems with
unstable dynamic because essentially
it's built on e to the eighty and e to
the 80 blows up
so I can't get the grammy in for the
pendulum up position so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to use the pendulum
down position linearize dynamics and
then the grammy and should work okay so
all i did was i switch this bit here so
now I'm looking at pendulum down
linearization now nothing changes I'm
going to pull out the three by three
subsystem because I only care about X
dot theta and theta dot I'm still going
to measure a theta dot and I'm going to
see what the volume of my observability
ellipsoid is okay so this is the volume
of my observability ellipsoid and let's
keep tracking this let's have a little
table let's say let's say that I have my
measurement Y and then the debt of this
observability gramming I'm going to call
it W oh okay okay good
so we're going to keep track of what
we're measuring and what the determinant
of this observability crime is so I just
measured theta dot and the determinant
was 0.03 okay okay so now let's say
instead of measuring theta dot let's
just say I measure theta
okay nothing changes all I did was I
just changed my
a C matrix here okay the code ran it
actually has exactly the same
determinant of the observability gram
and which i think is kind of interesting
so if i measure theta then I would also
have 0.03 volume of my observability
ellipsoid but now let's try measuring X
dot so instead of measuring theta or
theta dot I'm changing it here so I'm
measuring the first variable X dot if I
run this code you see that now my
determinant of my volume of my
observability ellipsoid if I measure X
dot is 50 okay so it's way way way
bigger it's many orders of magnitude
larger than if I measure theta or theta
dot okay so I find this very interesting
what this tells me is that I have a
larger volume of my observability
ellipsoid if I measure X dot than if I
measure theta or theta dot so in some
sense it's easier for me to observe my
system to estimate the full state if I
measure X dot if y equals x dot then FY
equals theta or theta dot now that's not
all of the story I really wanted to get
into this I look at what are the eigen
vector directions of this observability
gram and because maybe this is just
incredibly observable in one direction
and that's throwing this all off but I
doubt that so in general this kind of
tells me that X dot might be a better
measurement for my system I get a lot of
gain if I measure X dot and I can
estimate the rest of the states okay so
I just thought this is kind of cool you
can really quickly investigate which
measurements are good which measurements
are bad what is observable what's not
observable you can drop States if you
don't need them so here we drop to the X
state and just look at the 3x3 subsystem
and this is all you know just a couple
of lines in MATLAB OB sve and Graham
okay so next time we're actually going
to design a column and filter and
estimate the system thank you